im niedersächsischen Heidekreis zwischen
Hamburg und Hannover ist die aller über
die Ufer getreten Hochwasser kennen Sie
hier erzählt Familie klut aber diesmal
war es besonders
schlimm also da hinten ist eigentlich
Wiese
und wenn sie da in der Mitte den Baum
sehen dahinter geht eine Böschung auch
noch runter das sind eigentlich
überschwemmungswiesen die stehen auch
gelegentlich mal unter Wasser wir sind
am 26 ins Bett gegangen war so ah ja ist
schon ganz schön dicht ähm aber bis den
Garten komm es auf gar keinen Fall also
haben wir gesagt also wenn es im Garten
steht dann ist wirklich schlimm so ja
und dann sind wir ja morgens aufgewacht
und es war einfach da die cluts zeigen
uns Fotos auf denen zu sehen ist wie
hoch das Wasser stand erst seit dem 29
Dezember sinkt der Pegel allmählich alle
8 Stunden habe ich das halt hier
markiert und da haben wir uns halt auch
mit allen unseren Freunden hier zum Ort
gefreut dass die runtergehen also das
war
echt doch das Risiko dass das Hochwasser
zurückkommt steigt sagen
Meteorologen wir müssen uns auch in
Zukunft auf solche
Extremwetterereignisse einstellen also
dass es viel regnet und dass es dann zu
Überflutung kommt es ist letztendlich
Physik mit jedem Grad Erwärmung kann die
Luft 7% Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen also man
kann davon ausgehen dass wenn es in
Zukunft wärmer wird natürlich auch mehr
Feuchtigkeit aufgenommen wird von der
Luft und transp wird und das muss ja
irgendwo runterkommen häufigere
Extremwetterereignisse höhere
Pegelstände Deutschland will den
Klimawandel bekämpfen muss ich
gleichzeitig aber auch anpassen ein
Einsatzfahrzeug der Feuerwehr nimmt uns
mit in die Nachbargemeinde die Straße
ist überflutet der Hof von Landwirt
Steffen Meer aber ist trocken geblieben
er hat rechtzeitig vorgesorgt wir haben
die ganze Hoffläche auf der ich jetzt
hier gerade stehe bereits schon um 1,20
angehoben im Rahmen der ganzen
Renovierung und Instandsetzung dieses
Betriebes somit dass wir so ein bisschen
aus dieser Lage dieser dieser
gefährdeten Lage ein Stück weit
herauskommen und noch etwas länger ein
trockenen Fuß behalten können doch
Eigeninitiative wie die von Landwirt
Meer wird auf Dauer nicht reichen um
Deutschland vor den Folgen des
Klimawandels zu schützen eine Einsicht
die auch in der Bundespolitik angekommen
ist deshalb ist es gut dass wir mit dem
heutigen Tag erstmals ein Gesetz dazu
haben das deutsche
klimaanpassungsgesetz
Beifall im Bundestag weil es ein Gesetz
zur Anpassung an den Klimawandel gibt
Ende
2023 dabei gab es doch schon 2008 eine
deutsche Anpassungsstrategie an die
Folgen des Klimawandels initiiert vom
damaligen Umweltminister Sigmar Gabriel
mit der Verabschiedung der Strategie
positioniert sich die Bundesregierung
erstmals als Ganzes zum Thema Anpassung
an die Folgen des Klimawandels zwischen
der ersten Positionierung einer
Bundesregierung zur Klimaanpassung und
dem ersten Gesetz zur Klimaanpassung
liegen 15 Jahre und viele Hochwasser
2013 an der Elbe 2016 am Inn 2022 an der
Mosel und viele weitere Konsequenzen gab
es kaum wir merken halt immer wieder
eine gewisse katastrophendemenz oder
hochwasserdemenz nach dem Hochwasser ist
bei allen Betroffenen aber auch bei den
verschiedenen Institutionen bei der
Politik in der gesamten Gesellschaft die
ja Betroffenheit sehr hoch diese
Betroffenheit nimmt aber mit zunehmendem
zeitlichen Abstand zum hochmassereignis
immer mehr ab das gilt selbst für
Katastrophen wie die von
2021 bei der Flut im Westen Deutschlands
sterben allein im Aral mehr als 130
Menschen Häuser und Existenzen zerstört
was ist seither passiert in der kleinen
Gemeinde misch im Aril sind längst noch
nicht alle Schäden beseitigt und von den
wieder aufgebauten Gebäuden stehen viele
nach wie vor im Überflutungsgebiet
direkt an der
A klar Samarien rational betrachtet ist
natürlich nicht sinnvoll die S die
Häuser die zerstört worden sind oder
auch stark betroffen dass man die dann
wieder aufbaut aber das sind natürlich
ganz persönliche Dinge sind da hängen
sag Geschichten dran an den Häusern da
ist ja eine Historie mit verbunden
Heimatgefühl bis zur Flut stand auf
dieser freien Fläche das Haus von
hansgünz erine haben ihr Stück Heimat
verloren der Garten der war dahinter wir
ein schönen großen Garten mit über 100
Jahre alten
Apfelbäumen ist alles abrasiert an
gleicher Stelle wieder aufzubauen aber
kam für die korts nicht in Frage ihr
neues Zuh Hause haben sie etwas höher am
Hang gebaut sie hatten das Glück dass
die Gemeinde Ihnen das Grundstück
relativ günstig verkaufen konnte doch
die meisten Menschen im arartal bauen
ihre Häuser an Ort und Stelle wieder auf
für mich das kamikaz ich kann es nicht
nachvollziehen warum man das tut außer
halt eben dass es keine andere
Möglichkeit für die Betroffenen gibt als
da wieder aufzubauen wo sie sind aber
spätens an dem Punkt ist für mich
Politik und Verwaltung gefragt halt eben
dass die halt hingehen müssten müssten
ausgleichflächen zur Verfügung stellen
und sagen okay komm 50 m höher machen
wir jetzt Bauland das gilt nicht nur für
zerstörte Häuser deutschlandweit werden
nach wie vor Neubauten in
hochwassergefährdeten Gebieten errichtet
mit Ausnahmegenehmigung V Politik und
Verwaltung der Gesamtverband der
Versicherer kritisiert das seit Jahren
wir bauen im Grunde genommen in
Deutschland auch so als wenn es den
Klimawandel nicht gäbe was wir
beispielsweise fordern ist ein
neubauverbot in
überschwemmungsgefährdeten Gebieten das
gibt's in einigen anderen EU-Ländern
schon und wir haben in Deutschland in
den letzten 20 Jahren rund 32000 Häuser
gebaut in solchen extrem
überschwemmungsgefährdeten Gebieten die
Genehmigungen dafür erteilen im
Regelfall die Kommunen deswegen wollte
die Bundesregierung laut ihrem
Strategiepapier bereits 2008 Zitat mit
Vertretern interessierter Kommunen und
Kreise diskutieren durch welche
Maßnahmen und Hilfestellungen die
Entwicklung und Umsetzung von lokalen
anpassungskonzepten erfolgen kann der
Bund wollte die Kommunen also 2008 dabei
unterstützen konkrete Schutzmaßnahmen zu
entwickeln und umzusetzen 15 Jahre
später ist Gabriel Nachfolgerin Lemke
nicht viel weiter bei vielen Maßnahmen
vor Ort spielen die Kommunen die
entscheidende Rolle und mit dem Gesetz
werden wir Sie dabei unterstützen Ihre
konkreten Risiken zu
identifizieren die konkreten Risiken für
misch hat Bürgermeister Adriani längst
identifiziert entsprechende Pläne für
den Hochwasserschutz gibt es auch doch
die möglichen Schutzmaßnahmen bestehen
bis heute lediglich aus 50 cm hohen
plastikbarrieren warum das Problem ist
die Planung die wird relativ gut
gefördert aber die Umsetzung sprich wir
müssen jetzt anschaffen das
hochwasserschutzsystem kostet so round
100.000 € so und diese 100.000 € müssten
wir als Ortsgemeinde aufbringen da haben
wir natürlich gar kein Geld für Pläne
vor Ort gibt es doch das Geld dafür
fehlt ob Bund und Länder dafür aufkommen
verrät auch das neue
klimaanpassungsgesetz nicht dafür
verspricht es Zitat die
klimaanpassungsstrategie wird bis zum 30
September
vorgelegt 17 Jahre nach der ersten
Strategie will die Regierung also eine
Strategie vorlegen schriftlich haben wir
Umweltministerin Lemke gefragt warum die
Anpassung an den Klimawandel so langsam
vorangeht keine
Antwort Liliental bei Bremen
Feuerwehrleute verlegen einen mobilen
Deich schützen den Ort für den Fall dass
das Wasser noch höher steigt der Schaden
aber ist längst entstanden also ich
wohne hier am Ende von dem mobilen Deich
Haus ist gerade noch so mit eingedeicht
ab wir hatten glaube ich noch Glück dass
wir relativ schnell die Sachen dann noch
ausräumen konnten aus dem Keller so dass
es wohl erstmal nur die Bausubstanz
betrifft und dann das wahrscheinlich mit
dem Bautrockner dann auch zu machen ist
aber was sowas kostet das weiß ich nicht
da hat kein Erfahrung gehe davon aus
dass ich das alles privat bezahlen muss
ja vielleicht aber auch nicht
Spitzenpolitiker erscheinen auch diesmal
im Katastrophengebiet versprechen Hilfe
eine Rolle die sehr viel angenehmer ist
als unbequeme maßnah wie
siedlungsverbote oder Umsiedlungen zu
verlangen wie Sigma Gabriel schon vor 15
Jahren sagte ist es eben so dass man
sich wenn der Schaden eingetreten ist
einig darüber ist was man tun müsste
wenn der Schaden vier Wochen vorbei ist
beginnt die Debatte wieder sich
rückwärtsgerichte zu orientieren
Stillstand den sich Deutschland
angesichts des Klimawandels und seiner
Folgen kaum leisten
kann